- [Voiceover] The figure
above shows a string
with one end attached to an oscillator
and the other end
attached to a block there.
There's our block.
The string passes over a
massless pulley that turns
with negligible friction.
There's our massless pulley that turns
Four such strings, A, B, C,
and D are set up side-by-side
as shown in the figure
in the diagram below.
So this is a top view,
you can see oscillator.
This is a top view of the
oscillator string pulley
mass system, and we have four of them.
Each oscillator is adjusted
to vibrate the string
at its fundamental frequency f.
So let's think about what
it, I'll keep reading
then we'll think about what
fundamental frequency means.
The distance between each
oscillator and the pulley L
is the same.
So the length between the
oscillator and the pulley
is the same, and the mass
of each block is the same.
So the mass is what's providing
the tension in the string.
However, the fundamental
frequency of each string
is different.
So let's just first of all think about
what the fundamental frequency is,
and then let's think about
what makes them different.
So the fundamental frequency,
one way you could think about it is
it's the lowest frequency
that is going to produce
a standing wave in your string.
So it's the frequency that
produces a standing wave
that looks like this.
It's a standing wave where the
string is half a wavelength.
I guess there's two
ways to think about it.
It's the lowest frequency we could produce
the standing wave, or it's
the frequency at which
you're producing the
wave, the standing wave,
with the longest wavelength.
So the string at the fundamental frequency
is just going to go to, is gonna vibrate
between those two positions.
And you see here that the wavelength here
is twice the length of the string.
And if you want to see
that a little bit clearer,
if I were to continue with this wave,
I would have to go another
length of the string
in order to complete one wavelength.
Or another way to think about it,
you're going up, down, and
then you're going down back.
It's reflecting back off of this end here.
And as we mentioned, essentially
what the mass is doing
is providing the tension, the
force of gravity on this mass
is providing the tension in this string.
So the oscillators is vibrating
at the right frequency
to produce this, the lowest
frequency where you can produce
this standing wave.
So let's answer the questions
now, and we have four
of this set up and they all
have different frequencies.
The equation for the velocity
v of a wave on a string
is v is equal to the
square root of the tension
of the string divided by
the mass of the string
divided by the length of the string,
where F sub T is tension of the string
and m divided by L is
the mass per unit length,
linear mass density of the string.
And hopefully this makes sense.
It makes sense that it's
going to be that if,
if the tension increases, that
your velocity will increase,
the tension, you could think
of the atoms of the string
of how much they're pulling on each other.
And so if there's higher tension, well,
they're going to be able
to move each other better,
or I guess you could say
accelerate each other better
as the wave goes through the string.
And also make sense that
the larger the mass,
if you hold everything else equal,
that you're gonna have a slower velocity.
Mass, you could view it
as a measure of inertia,
it's how hard it is
to accelerate something.
So if the string itself,
especially the mass
per unit length, if there's a
lot of mass per unit length,
actually, let me circle
that because that's actually
the more interesting thing.
If there's a lot of mass per unit length,
it makes sense that for a
given amount of the string,
it's gonna be harder to
accelerate it back and forth
as you vibrate it.
And so this part right over
here would be inversely related
to the velocity.
It's not proportional though.
You have this square root here,
but they're definitely,
if the linear mass density increases,
then you're gonna have a slower velocity.
And if your tension increases,
you're going to have
a higher velocity.
So hopefully this makes
some intuitive sense.
And they ask, what is the
difference about the four string
shown above that would
result in having different
fundamental frequencies?
Explain how you arrive at your answer.
And then part b is
student graphs frequency
is a function of the inverse
of the linear mass density.
Will the graph be linear?
Explain how you arrived at your answer.
All right, let's answer each of these.
So a, part a, what is different
about the four strings
because they all have different
fundamental frequencies?
So the fundamental frequency,
let's just go back to
what we know about waves,
that the velocity of a wave
is equal to the frequency
times the wavelength of the wave.
Or you could say, you could
divide both sides by lambda,
you could say that the frequency of a wave
is equal to the velocity
over the velocity over
the wavelength.
So if we're talking about
the fundamental frequency,
if we're talking about
funda, let me just,
let me write frequency and
then let me write fundamental
real small here.
Fundamental, the fundamental frequency,
is going to be the velocity of our waves
divided by the wavelength is
going to be twice the length
of our string, divided by two L.
And if you look at the
expression that they gave us
for the velocity of
the wave on the string,
well, this is going to be equal to
the square root of the
tension in the string
divided by, divided by
the linear mass density.
Divided by the linear mass density.
And all of that is going to be over two L.
Now all of them have different
fundamental frequencies,
but let's think about
what's different over here.
They all have the same tension.
How do I know that?
Well, what's causing the
tension is the masses
hanging over the pulleys.
So the weight of those masses.
So that's all going to be
the same for all of them,
and they all have the same length.
They all have the same length.
So these are all the same.
So the only way that you're
going to have different
fundamental frequencies is
if you have different masses.
So different masses.
So that has to be different.
Different.
So to answer their question,
the strings must have different mass,
well, they would have different
linear mass densities,
but since they're all the same length,
they would also have different masses.
So let me write this down.
Strings, strings must
have different,
different masses
and mass densities,
densities, since
all other variables
driving, driving
fundamental frequency are the same,
fundamental frequency
are the same,
are the same.
All right, let's tackle part b now.
A student graphs frequency as a function
of the inverse of linear mass density.
Will the graph be linear?
Explain how you arrived at your answer.
So student graphs frequency.
Let me underline this.
They're graphing frequency as a function
of linear mass density.
So we actually can write this down.
If we wanted to write frequency
as a function of linear mass densities,
so we could write as a
function of m over L,
well, this is going to be equal to,
is going to be equal to,
we could rewrite this expression,
actually, we could just
leave it like this.
This is the same thing as one over two L
times the square root of the tension
divided by the linear mass density.
Or you can do this as being equal to,
you could say this is a square root of
the tension over two L,
and I'm putting all of
this separate because
we're doing it as a function
of our linear mass density.
So we can assume that all of
this is going to be a constant.
And then times the square root
of one over the linear mass density.
So if you're plotting, if
you're plotting frequency
as a function of this,
it's not going to be,
the graph is definitely
not going to be linear.
You see here, one, I have
the reciprocal of it,
and then I take the square root of it.
So let me write this down.
This f or graph of f of two L,
definitely not linear.
Let me write it that way.
F of m over L graph,
definitely, definitely
not linear.
And you could point out
that it has a reciprocal
and it's a square root.
Involves, involves square root
and inverse,
or I could say and
reciprocal of the variable.
And reciprocal, reciprocal
of the linear mass density
of m over L.
So definitely not linear.
All right, let's tackle part c.
The frequency of the oscillator
connected to string D
is changed so that the string vibrates
in its second harmonic.
On the side view of string D below,
mark and label the points
on the string that have
the greatest average vertical speed.
So one way to think about
the fundamental frequency,
that's our first harmonic.
So if they're talking
about the first harmonic
and the string is what I showed before,
that's the lowest frequency
that produces a standing wave
or it's the frequency
that produces the largest
standing wave, I guess
you could say the one
with the largest wavelength.
And if it was a first harmonic,
the part of the string that moves the most
is going to be that center.
But our second harmonic is
the next highest frequency
that produces a standing wave,
and that's going to be
a situation in which
the wave, instead of having
a wavelength twice the length
of the string, it's
gonna have a wavelength
equal to the length of the string.
So now, it's going to look like this.
So it's going to vibrate between this,
actually, let me draw it a
little bit neater than that.
It's going to vibrate between,
between this.
And so
it's gonna vibrate between that and this.
And this right over here.
So when you see this, this version of it,
where now that we have
half the wavelength,
the wavelength is exactly
the wavelength of,
it's actually L this time,
the part that moves the most is here.
So that's going to move the most.
And here.
I didn't draw it perfectly.
But one way to think
about it, it's exactly 1/4
and 3/4 of the way.
Exactly halfway is not
going to move as much,
is not gonna move because
it's a standing wave now
or it's gonna move very imperceptibly.
These two places are where
you're gonna move the most
at the first, or sorry,
at the second harmonic.
The second harmonic being
the next highest frequency
that produces a standing wave again.